[Musik]
es gibt offiziell noch keinen neuen us
präsidenten aber einen der sich so
verhält und damit guten morgen und
herzlich willkommen zu diesem heute
spezial joe biden hat sich in der nacht
ans amerikanische volk gewandt dabei
erklärte er sich ausdrücklich nicht zum
wahlsieger denn noch immer wird in den
besonders umkämpften staaten ausgezählt
aber er hat klar gemacht was mit ihm als
präsident geschehen soll
sofortige kroner maßnahmen auch der
wirtschaft soll geholfen werden
vor allem aber sei es an der zeit den
zorn im land abzulegen und gemeinsam als
eine nation zu heilen
donald trump der sich in der wahlnacht
bereits als sieger bezeichnet hatte
schrieb auf twitter beiden sollen nicht
fälschlicherweise das amt des
präsidenten für sich beanspruchen es
sollte eine siegesrede werden der
auftritt in seinem heimatstaat delaware
offiziell aber können sich joe biden
noch nicht zum künftigen us präsidenten
erklären
und doch zeigte sich siegessicher
erzählen eine klare geschichte
wir werden dieses rennen gewinnen
schauen wir was seit gestern passiert
ist vor 24 stunden lagen wir in georgia
hinten jetzt liegen wir vorn und werden
den start gewinnen
vor 24 stunden lagen in pennsylvania
hinten und nun werden wir pennsylvania
gewinnen
niemals in der us-geschichte habe ein
kandidat so viele stimmen bekommen wie
er so beiden von 74 millionen spricht er
mehr als 70 millionen haben allerdings
für trump gestimmt die tiefe spaltung im
land will beiden überwinden
ziel unserer politik ist es nicht das
feuer des konflikts zu schüren sondern
probleme zu lösen gerechtigkeit zu
garantieren jedem eine faire chance zu
geben und das leben der menschen zu
verbessern
wir müssen ruhig bleiben geduldig warten
wir den prozess ab während alle stimmen
gezählt werden kann
beiden gibt sich staatsmännisch das land
wieder zu einem sei sein ziel
schließlich so beiden sind demokraten
und republikaner gegner keine feinde in
der heimat von joe biden im us
bundesstaat delaware in wilmington hat
johannes hano diesen auftritt verfolgt
johannes live dabei wie hat dies rede
auf die teilnehmer gewirkt so viele
teilnehmer waren das gar nicht er hatte
die rede an das volk gerichtet dabei saß
in einem pressezentrum in seinem
hauptquartier und hat von dort
ausgesprochen aber für viele amerikaner
war das sehr sehr wohl tun es ging vor
allem um amerika und nicht um ihn selbst
und erhard töne angeschlagen
die man in den vergangenen jahren je in
amerika nicht gehört hat er hat wie wir
schon gehört haben um aus sich um
aussöhnung bemüht er hat davon
gesprochen dass man nicht sich
gegenseitig den krieg erklären soll
sondern dass man aufeinander zugehen
müsse dass man versuchen müsse dass man
zwar politisch unterschiedlicher meinung
sein kann dass man eine politische
gegnerschaft haben kann aber dass man
keine feinde seien alles amerikaner hat
er den zuhören zugeworfen hier an das
volk und insofern sind viele amerikaner
sehr hoffnungsfroh dass ich mit diesen
wahrscheinlich neuen präsidenten auch
ein neuer ton im weißen haus
einschleicht wir haben auszüge gehört
wie gerade schon zitiert aber nochmal
ins detail was hat sich joe biden
tatsächlich vorgenommen wenn er
präsident wird also hat ganz klar gesagt
diese wahl werde ein mandat dafür sein
sich jetzt ganz sofort intensiv mit der
lösung der krise die ein riesen thema
ist auseinanderzusetzen
er hat davon gesprochen dass man den
klimawandel angehen muss auch so ein
thema das in den letzten vier jahren
quasi brach gelegen hat und er hat und
das kriegt er sich ganz klar und seine
vielen unterstützer hier
er hat gesagt man müsse das problem des
rassismus in den griff bekommen das
seien die drei größten probleme und auch
wenn er noch nicht zum sieger auserkoren
sei so hätte er doch schon mit der
arbeit angefangen habe ich und briefings
gehabt zu den bestimmten themen zu kurve
zu wirtschaft da will also jetzt sofort
loslegen und er hat klar gemacht dass er
von tag eins an bereit sein wird diese
großen themen anzugehen
danke für ihre eindrücke und
schilderungen johannes hano live aus
gründen
donald trump hat erneut deutlich gemacht
dass er nicht bereit ist die sich
abzeichnende niederlage anzuerkennen er
kündigte an sich mit einer ganzen serie
von klagen ein bisschen darauf zum
obersten gericht zu wehren
er sei opfer eines systematischen
wahlbetrugs dafür aber gibt es nach wie
vor keine beweise
seine anhänger aber stehen ihm bei und
einige sogar wild entschlossen
[Musik]
zählen und warten warten und zählen
ununterbrochen berichten die us medien
wie sich die mehrheitsverhältnisse in
den entscheidenden staaten pennsylvania
georgia arizona und nevada verschieben
mit nahezu platz ihrer langsamkeit aber
scheinbar unaufhaltsam zu gunsten von
joe biden vielen trump anhängern im land
ist das nicht geheuer
so wie hier in detroit demonstrieren sie
vor den auszählung zentren
das ist schwer zu akzeptieren man geht
am wahlabend ins bett donald trump führt
und um vier uhr morgens tauchen dann auf
mysteriöse weise diese ganzen stimmen
für beiden auf das ergibt doch keinen
sinn
jumper doch befürchtet dass es zu betrug
kommen würde und ich glaube dass auch
die briefwahlstimmen sind doch der
ideale vorwand für wahlbetrug
donald trump hat die zweifel an der
rechtmäßigkeit der wahl immer weiter an
mit erfolg die verschwörungstheorien
schießen wie pilze aus dem boden
in arizona zum beispiel geht das gerücht
um die behörden hätten mit absicht
filzstifte ausgegeben die die
stimmzettel von champagnern unleserlich
machen er besonders innenministerin
widerspricht kein einziger stimmzettel
war ungültig weil er mit einem filzstift
ausgefüllt wurde eine haltlose
verschwörungstheorie die sich wie ein
lauffeuer verbreitet hat und wegen der
wir jetzt auch noch ein
gerichtsverfahren am hals haben viele
jump wähler in dem wüstenstaat aber
lassen sich von solchen beteuerungen
nicht beirren
diese wahl wird uns unter der nase weg
geklaut
wir sind überzeugt dass wir gewinnen
es kann doch nicht einfach in der früh
um vier die stimmzettel vorbeikommen und
hunderttausend stimmen ausschütten alle
für joe biden jeder der ein hirn hat sie
doch dass das betrug ist
falls joe biden gewinnt hat er ein
hartes stück arbeit vor sich seine
mitbürger zu vereinen und ihr vertrauen
in die demokratie wiederherzustellen
total jäger in washington wie stehen die
chancen dass trump juristisch erfolg
haben wird also nicht besonders gut denn
wer vor gericht erfolg haben möchte der
muss ja erstmal beweise vorlegen dass es
überhaupt wahlbetrug gegeben hat und das
hat das tram team bisher nicht getan
wir hören dass der präsident wohl
ziemlich unzufrieden ist mit der arbeit
seiner juristen und er sucht jetzt
weitere rechtsexperten die sein team
verstärken können aber dem präsident ist
wahrscheinlich in erster linie zweierlei
wichtig erst mal zeit schinden also so
lange wie möglich herauszögern dass joe
biden zum wahlsieger erklärt wird und
zum anderen wird trump wahrscheinlich
auch seinen anhängern und möglicherweise
auch sich selber einimpfen wollen dass
er eben um den wahlsieg betrogen worden
ist denn so könnte er dann mit der
legende abtreten dass er nie verloren
hat man hat nicht den eindruck dass
trumps sich bemüht deeskalierend zu
wirken welche gefahr beschwerde
wir sehen jetzt schon seit tagen die
trump anhänger machen extrem mobil sie
gehen raus vor die auszählung zentren
demonstrieren einige bringen auch ihre
waffen mit und man weiß auch dass einige
von diesen hardcore anhängern auch
bereit sind möglicherweise weiter zu
gehen als eben nur auf die straße zu
gehen und wenn ja wenn joe biden über
zusammenhalt spricht davon dass er die
nation wieder einen will dann klingt das
erst mal sehr schön aber wie realistisch
ist das denn
denn zumindest dieser hardcore trump
anhänger die werden immer der meinung
sein dass beiden sich seine
präsidentschaft erschlichen hat dass er
durch betrug ins weiße haus einziehen
konnte und die dann mit ins boot zu
holen bei diesen plan das ist doch zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt zumindest relativ
utopisch danke für diesen ausblick nach
washington britta jäger und damit der
blick nach pennsylvania dort wo die
entscheidung in kürze fallen kann
96 prozent der stimmen sind ausgezählt
beiden führt derzeit wenn auch nur knapp
der gewinner von pennsylvania bekommt 20
weitere war leute eine hohe zahl für
beiden würde das bedeuten er hätte die
marke von 270 nötigen wahlleuten
geknackt nach anordnung des obersten
gerichtshofs müssen dort allerdings die
briefwahlstimmen die nach dem tag der
wahl eingegangen sind gesondert
ausgewertet werden die republikaner
sehen diese stimmen als illegal an
fragen wir auch danach alissa jung ist
für uns in pennsylvania gehen wir das
mal genauer durch es geht um die stimmen
die nach schließung der wahllokale
eingetroffen sind und die so verlangt es
der supreme court getrennt von den
anderen ausgezählt werden sollen was
würden sie ohnehin aber was heißt das
sind die ungültig oder was ist der zweck
dieser maßnahmen nein die stimmen sind
nicht ungültig also die werden wieder
richtig gesagt hast also getrennt
ausgezählt und das wurden sie vor allem
auch schon die ganze zeit und das ist
nämlich der entscheidende punkt also
dieses urteil das gab es schon und da
ist es jetzt so dass der demokratische
generalstaatsanwalt hier von
pennsylvania gesagt hat das ist im
prinzip jetzt gar keinen gewinn für die
für die republikaner sondern was er
naja ne art niederlage weil also wie
gesagt das haben die ganze zeit schon so
gemacht sie werden getrennt also
gesammelt und sie werden vor allem auch
weiter ausgezählt sie beobachten die
situation in pennsylvania seit tagen was
hören sie was sagen die leute zu dieser
hängepartie
also ich hier vor im prinzip vor dem vor
dem zentrum vor dem kongresszentrum wo
die stimmen ausgezählt werden kann sich
heute den ganzen tag menschen versammelt
also von beiden seiten das waren nämlich
dann die tram fenster die auch ganz klar
wie der präsident von fälschungen
sprechen und fordern eine neuauszählung
der stimmen also eine komplette
neuauszählung und dann man aber auch
ganz viele die sagen also jede stimme
zählt und hier soll natürlich jede
stimme weiter ausgezählt werden
und die sagen also auch ganz klar hier
soll auf gar keinen fall ein stopp
passieren und da stehen sich wirklich
also zwei seiten relativ unversöhnlich
gegenüber und was vor allem auch ganz
wichtig ist also ich meine jetzt müssen
tatsächlich für diese ganzen
anschuldigung auch erstmal die die
belege und die beweise her
vielen dank weil dieser jungen für ihre
eindrücke
und damit weiter nach arizona ein staat
der seit bill clinton seit 1996 von
keinen demokraten mehr gewonnen werden
konnte auch der erscheint stand jetzt
mehrheitlich für joe biden gestimmt zu
haben
fox news der sender der donald trump
sehr zugeneigt ist hatte arizona schon
früh als erster amerikanischer tv sender
joe biden zu gerechnet was trump sehr
verärgerte offiziell ist das nicht so
der trend aber ist auch hier ein
deutlich sie wollen das weiter gezählt
wird für trump nach auszählung von 97
prozent der stimmen führt beiden derzeit
mit 49,6 prozent vor trump mit 48,7
er liegt zurück doch hunderte
unterstützer sind da und fordern zählt
jede stimme
ich glaube an trump ich werde für ihn
kämpfen auf beiden sieg gebe ich nichts
er kann nur durch betrug gewinnen wahre
amerikanische patrioten haben jump
gewählt ich gehe für ihn bis zur hölle
und zurück
jump ist der richtige mann für amerika
er ist der richtige mann für die welt er
ist wo er sein soll in dieser zeit ohne
trump wird die welt leiden wenn er
verliert
es wird keine gute welt werden die
polizei ist vor ort die stimmung ist
angespannt
trumps anhänger sprechen immer wieder
von wahlbetrug ohne dass es beweise gibt
sie waren vom kommunismus bill gates und
den medien dazwischen wird gebetet in
phoenix in arizona jan fritsche wir
leben sie die stadt in diesen tagen wir
haben einige gehört aber was sagen denn
die mehrheit der tramp anhänger glauben
sie diese verschwörungstheorie ja werden
wir gerade die bilder gesehen und heute
sind die trump anhänger auch wieder vor
die wahlbehörde gezogen und haben wieder
diesen wahlbetrug geltend gemacht den
sie da wittern und da gibt es
verschiedene verschwörungs erzählungen
die sie davor bringen also da ist zum
einen die vermutungen dass
möglicherweise stimmen die von
republikanern abgegeben worden seien für
deutschland einfach nicht gezählt worden
sein könnten einfach in den mülleimer
geschmissen worden sind dass das zweite
was sie sagen ist das möglicherweise
auch die stimmen von toten gezählt
worden sein
was also auch zu einer wahlfälschung
beitragen
würde und das dritte sharp igate hören
wir seit kurzem das heißt das also
filzstifte ausgegeben worden seien um
die wahlzettel auszufüllen und dass die
wahlmaschinen diese filzstifte aber gar
nicht lesen können und dadurch wiederum
stimmen nicht hätten ausgezahlt werden
können also da sind schon einige wilde
verschwörungstheorien die wahlbehörde
selbst hat sich dazu geäußert habe
gesagt das ist alles völliger blödsinn
hat überhaupt keine realität keine
grundlage und wir haben auch hier mit
einer wahlhelferin sprechen können die
uns gesagt hat das sind immer demokraten
und republikaner bei der stimmauszählung
dabei es geht alles mit rechten dingen
zu und sie es erschüttert weil sie so
was in ihren 66 jahren die sie hier es
noch nie erlebt hat dass die menschen
jeglicher realität grundlage entbehren
und diese verschwörungstheorien
vorbringen wir haben fritzsche vielen
dank für diese eindrücke aus arizona
eins ist sicher der nächste
amerikanische präsident wird am 20
januar 2021 vereidigt das sieht die
verfassung so vor dieser termin aber
setzt fristen und genau das bestimmt das
kalkül der juristen die nun ins feld
ziehen
der nächste wichtige termin ist der safe
harbor day am 8
dezember bis zu diesem tag müssen die
wahlergebnisse zertifiziert und
wahlleute bestimmt sein
ist das nicht der fall zum beispiel weil
immer noch vor gericht um die wahl
gestritten wird könnte es knifflig
werden
eine möglichkeit die parlamente oder
gouverneure in umkämpften staaten
ernennen wahlleute juristisch wäre das
wohl möglich am 14 dezember soll
eigentlich in jedem staat das elektro
college das kollegium der wahlleute
zusammentreten und über den neuen
präsidenten abstimmen
was aber wenn immer noch über die
verteilung der wahlleute gestritten wird
dann könnte der kongress ins spiel
kommen eine entscheidung getroffen von
den abgeordneten denkbar aber in der
nahen vergangenheit ist das nie
eingetreten und die rechtlichen
grundlagen dafür sind schwammig das
ganze könnte letztlich noch vor dem
supreme court landen
am 20 januar 2021 soll der neue
präsident vereidigt werden je klarer das
wahlergebnis ausfällt je mehr starten
die demokraten gewinnen desto
unwahrscheinlicher ist das szenario und
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es dass joe
biden neuer präsident wird
stop the count hört auf zu zählen hatte
donald trump in großbuchstaben
getwittert weil er sich im vorsprung
wähnte
und bei aller schwere und wichtigkeit
dieser entscheidung so ist es doch der
humor der am ende alles erträglich macht
wer weiß das besser als die briten dort
führt der fc southampton gerade durchaus
überraschen die tabelle in der premier
league an vor liverpool
diese tabelle twitter der verein mit der
überschrift stop the count naja das
spiel aber geht weiter
und auch wir bleiben weiter dran an
dieser präsidentschaftswahl für den
moment aber sagen wir danke für ihr
interesse
kommen sie gut an wenn tag und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]